I'm very grateful for being here
to share with you
that I live in a country, Uruguay,
where about 98 percent of its electricity
is obtained from a combination
of different renewable sources.
A country whose inhabitants emit
30 times less greenhouse gases
than the world average
for each kilowatt hour consumed.
A country that produces
its electricity at a fixed cost,
regardless of wars
or other geopolitical events
since it is almost independent
on energy commodities,
dependent just on its wind,
its sun, its water, its biomass waste.
A country that exports renewable energy
surpluses to its two giant neighbors,
Argentina and Brazil.
When I tell people about Uruguay,
they usually say two things.
"I never heard about this.
How did you do it?"
And, "Can this be replicated elsewhere?"
So today I want to tell you what happened
in Uruguay, how we did it.
And yes, even if every country
would have to define
its own transition journey,
the Uruguayan solution can definitely
be replicated elsewhere.
Fifteen years ago, the Uruguayan
energy sector was going to a deep crisis.
Economy was growing
in unprecedented rates
and poverty was decreasing,
which was so great, of course,
but at the same time,
energy demand was growing rapidly,
which was not so great.
Uruguay has no proven reserve
for fossil fuels.
We have already used our large rivers
to install hydropower plants
and our two big neighbors
were having their own difficulties
to supply internal demand,
so it was not easy for them to help us.
In dry years,
when you have to import
much more fossil fuels,
we were forced to import electricity
from our neighbors
at extraordinary prices.
Cost overruns could be
as high as one billion dollars.
And for a small economy like Uruguay,
this is two percent of its GDP.
And worse still, we were beginning
to have blackouts.
We were living the perfect storm.
But crisis is also opportunity.
For most of my life, I was a scientist,
a particle physicist,
doing research on subjects far removed
from the everyday world.
But in that particular national
energy context,
I saw the need to reinvent myself,
to get involved
in the search for solutions.
I began to study the energy issue,
to organize seminars,
to discuss with different experts,
and I realized how complex
the energy issue is,
how many dimensions it has.
Technological and economical
dimensions, of course,
but also environmental,
social, geopolitical,
cultural and even ethical dimensions.
I started to write down my thoughts
and almost without realizing,
I ended up with a comprehensive,
holistic proposal
focused on a just transition
to renewable energies
with very ambitious goals.
And one day,
when I was in my office at university,
I received an unexpected call.
My proposal had reached the president
and he was inviting me to implement it.
Imagine my surprise.
He was inviting me
to be the political head
of our national energy agency,
what in the United States
would be a Secretary of Energy.
I accepted, and we immediately began
to implement that policy.
But before the result could be fully seen,
there was an election.
Fortunately, the new
president, José Mujica,
was supportive of what
we had started to do
and he asked me to remain in office.
But he asked me one important point:
to make this policy to be accepted
by all political parties.
Patiently, we negotiated with all parties
represented in Parliament
and we achieved our goal after
they accepted some minor changes.
Having a long-term policy
backed by the entire
Uruguayan political system
was crucial to make rapid progress.
In just five years,
we went from a traditional
hydrothermal power mix
with up to 50 percent fossil share
to an almost completely decarbonized one
that already in 2017
was 98 percent renewable.
What makes the
Uruguayan case unique
is that almost half of that electricity
is obtained from non-traditional
renewable sources.
Wind, solar and sustainable biomass.
Wind alone can produce up to 40 percent
of the total electricity
consumed in the country in a year,
a percentage comparable to the other
world wind champion, Denmark.
But also 15 or even 20 percent
of our electricity
is obtained with sustainable biomass.
Uruguay is an agro-industrial country
with abundant organic waste
that has a lot of energy content
like rice husks, bagasse,
black liquors from pulp mills.
They have now ceased to be
an environmental liability
to become an energy asset.
Of course, none of this was easy.
We have to innovate.
We have to understand
that such a power system
requires the planning
and operation quite different
than the traditional one.
Our academics worked for years
to design a groundbreaking software
to handle energy dispatch,
specifically designed to manage
intermittent sources
such as wind and solar,
but also how to use water.
This model is based on the probability
of occurrence of different
weather scenarios
based on both a century
of historical data
and weather forecast.
This allows us, for example,
to have a prediction of the amount
of wind electricity and solar electricity
that we're going to have in the grid
with a week in advance.
And this also allows us to know
how and when we have to use
water from the dams.
Thanks to this disruptive methodology,
today in Uruguay,
intermittent sources are king.
The total installed capacity
of wind plus solar
is of the order of the total
country's peak demand.
This means that when we have
enough wind and solar,
almost 100 percent of electricity
is just from these two sources alone,
in addition to biomass-fired power plant.
And this may happen many times
during the course of a week.
And in those moments,
we don't use water from the dams.
Hydropower plant only comes into play
when the sun goes down
or when the wind falls.
Our insurance policy,
when all else fails, are gas turbines,
combined cycle and engine power plant.
Yes, of course,
flexible fossil-fired power
plants remain there,
but we rely on them very little
over the course of a year,
allowing non-renewable electricity
to be no more than two percent
of the electricity in the grid
in a regular year,
and sometimes six or seven percent
in a very dry one.
And get this.
We achieve this goal without
any single battery storage,
water pumping or any modern technology
for electricity storage.
Uruguay has shown
that the power mix can work
almost exclusively thanks
to the complementarity
of different renewable sources
independently of their
individual intermittency.
And this is perhaps the time
for you to ask the question,
“And what happened to the economy?
How much did all this cost?”
And the answer is even more radical.
The cost was negative,
if I may put it this way.
In fact, we get an impressive
positive impact to our economy.
To begin with,
the total cost to produce
electricity all over a year
was reduced by almost half.
No surprise, renewable energies
are the cheapest option today.
We went from about 1.1 billion dollar cost
to only 600 million dollars today.
And this impressive
500 million dollars every year
for a country like Uruguay is huge.
It's one percent of its GDP.
Just for comparison,
one percent of United States GDP,
it's about 250 billion dollars annually.
Moreover, those tremendous cost overruns
that we had in dry years,
well, they virtually disappeared.
We went from cost overruns
of about one billion dollars,
to only 100 to perhaps 200 million a year
in very dry ones.
Surprisingly enough
now, though, to have much more
natural sources in the grid,
because of their complementarity,
we are much less dependent
on weather variability.
Of course, achieving this tremendous
cost reduction was not easy either.
We have to innovate also on that.
We have to understand
that renewable energies
require a business model
quite different from the traditional one
of the power sectors all over the world.
We have to create a new market model.
Our present business model
is based on long-term contracts
derived from auction processes
in which the percentage
of this source is predetermined
using an optimization model
that defines which is the best
technical complementarity
between sources
in order to minimize
the overall cost of the system.
Thanks to this, nowadays,
almost 100 percent
of our electricity generation
is under contract,
leaving almost no space
for the spot market
and also no space for uncertainties.
The comprehensive model
we had defined and put in place
not only allows us to strongly
reduce the overall costs,
but also to stabilize it over time.
The cost to produce electricity
in Uruguay today is stabilized.
Think it is almost independent
of the fluctuation of the prices
of energy commodities.
Thanks to this, for example,
the Uruguayan electric mix
was barely affected
by the tragic war in Europe.
We had no supply
nor affordability difficulties.
But the positive economic impact
of this transformation
went far beyond just the electric sector.
We achieved a tremendous
impact to our economy.
We received six billion
dollars in investment.
This is 12 percent of our GDP.
Imagine the impact to our economy.
New knowledge, new industrial,
entrepreneurial capabilities,
50,000 jobs were created.
This seems small, perhaps for you,
but for a country with only
3.4 million inhabitants,
it represents three percent
of its labor force.
Once again, if we were made
to make a comparison,
three percent of the United
States labor force
is several million new jobs created.
So I told you a little about what happened
in Uruguay and how we did it.
But you may be thinking,
“OK, but that’s Uruguay,
fine, but that's Uruguay.
It's a small country.
They have a unique culture.
They have hydro.
Can this be reproduced elsewhere?”
So I want to be very emphatic on this.
Although each country will have to define
its own transition process,
the vast majority of countries can make
a process similar to the Uruguayan one.
(Applause)
You don't necessarily need a lot of hydro
backup capacity, but for sure,
you need to put much more
flexibility to your system
with a new dispatch model,
a new market model.
But if you have people and companies
doing research and developing AI
and artificial intelligence and rockets,
developing a new market model,
a new energy management,
shouldn't be that hard.
By doing this,
we will probably not get the fossil
share down to two percent,
but for sure it will be below 15
or even 20 percent
and in many countries,
much less than that.
And you know what,
for the last couple of years
after leaving the government,
I've been working in a number of countries
from Dominican Republic to Chile
and many other countries
in Latin America, but also in Europe,
and other regions.
And the good news is
that the Uruguayan solution can work
in different national and energy context.
But for that, there is one
special ingredient.
You need to have a strong leadership
and a strong political will
to move forward.
And for that,
it's mostly recommended to build
a broad political agreement
that transcends the administration
in office in order to be sure
that the transition will continue in time.
What is then the most important
message for you today?
It is very simple.
That renewables are no longer
just a solution for the climate crisis.
Renewables allow us to build strong,
reliable, robust power systems.
They allow us to sharply reduce
and stabilize the electricity costs,
while at the same time
having an important energy boost
to our economies and job creation.
Lessons learned from the Uruguayan case
are that renewable energies
are ripe to provide
not just a climate solution
on a global scale,
but also substantial socio-economic
benefits at a local level.
And this can and should happen now.
There's no reason to wait until 2040,
not even 2030.
Now.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)